election 2013 what does the CSU want in
the interview CSU leading candidate
gotta hustle said for hustle field it
seems hassle fast the CSU the Christian
social Union is unique in Germany it
exists only in Bavaria which it has been
governing for more than half a century
and almost always with an absolute
majority where has the party's success
come from that sees Louis claw becomes
recently is the identified Sheeran that
sees it I think the CSU's identification
with Bavaria is absolutely essential
we're running for election in Bavaria
only we represent the special interests
of Bavarians not only there but in
Berlin as well and yet we never lose
sight of the German people as a whole in
Bavaria though we have a special
situation through the diverse landscape
the connection with our rich culture and
history and that all holds the people
there together and I think the CSU
embodies this union in a very special
way so dinky stinking space on the
revised it who is this correspondence
still astonishing all the big parties
are eroding both regionally and at the
federal level while the CSU is probably
this country's last real mass membership
party this is in der tod so if Flavio
afters that's indeed show I agree that
we're really unique as a party for me
personally that's also the reason I
joined the party because all kinds of
professions all social classes all age
groups are really represented and we've
had to find compromises within the party
at times as well secondly it's also the
combination of basic values and answers
to new challenges today's challenges no
I was for the Roman I've liked that
always poses a big task for a mass
membership party
and I think we've accomplished those
tasks in the past successfully over and
over may I forgive a ticket well done
bird scans completed but that's not all
although the CSU is actually just a
regionally anchored party it's also had
incredible influence first in bond and
now in Berlin it's a big plan that began
with party patriarch franz josef strauss
and it remains an important factor
through its cooperation with its sister
party the Christian Democratic Union
what does the CSU add to this union with
Indian fist the bastante lind example we
are an essential part of the cdu/csu
group in parliament without us nothing
would move forward within the group
that's your needs yeah I'm just enjoying
this legislative term we've also
demonstrated that on several issues such
as subsidizing stay-at-home parents
along this group if the CSU hadn't
fought for that resolutely we wouldn't
have reached the results we did within
the coalition cities my geekness key
common another example is heightened
infrastructure investment ideas these
are all ideas that originated in Bavaria
Duncan ed and they were brought into
national politics by an Harold's and
they prevailed there some traction with
anger profit wooden souvenir for Gregg
wins easy substance if you're a CSU
member you would probably identify
yourself as Christian conservative and
socially responsible is there anything
you would add to that me a bit Thornton
cut this is redic chris lee ogi that's
correct conservative christians in
socially conscious and conservative that
way we keep things that are worth
keeping while also facing up to new
challenges such as child care we're
observing changing conditions and family
policy that require solutions and we
provide them without throwing the status
of marriage into question interesting
that phone EA on familia in father's day
schwanke demands a spirit of the moment
nine over seas mi vida and it stuck no
but it's always a big challenge to keep
your basic values for example a high
regard for child-rearing
the family without losing sight of
today's necessities the two have to be
reconciled we see this clearly in family
issues we don't want to make families
decisions for them or dictate how
they're supposed to live on the contrary
we want them to decide freely in the
knowledge that the state will support
them whatever their decision may be at
sea by decent inside on the album as the
outfit understood you touched on the
angle two daughters and granddaughters
in the CSE one just homemakers enemy
their grandmothers probably don't live
next door either for that very reason
childcare is likely also a problem for
the CSU in rural areas as much as in
cities guys is nicotine weren't
engrossed it that's right and my guitar
that it's not just in cities as people
used to think but also in the
countryside well educated women today
want to or have to or think they have to
get a job however they decide families
have become smaller and therefore
childcare has taken on greater
importance than was the case earlier and
by the way that goes not only for
children under three who are the ones in
focus these days but also for school
children it's so up to alien for
Christine zaandam and it's certainly
important when the kids hit puberty when
problems often first crack in the potato
ton of the st problema of 34 has
affinities with Miss hassle fell to the
CSU has always been a party of domestic
security it proudly points to the
various low crime rate the German
interior minister a CSU man is in a
tough position US intelligence has been
snooping in Germany people are asking
what's more important security or
freedom what does the CSU say it isn't
fragen is in the tart and up these
issues really do require assessment I up
big we have to constantly way individual
liberty against security for citizens
sensitivity for the protection of
personal information it's probably more
pronounced in Germany than in some other
places you break ties in that much
be respected and ending is alkenyl Sutra
and finding a balance between security
on the one hand and liberty on the other
is the job of the interior minister and
all policymakers boom is in administers
and alphaville an ensign in the politic
god sent by shooter germany was shocked
when it became known that the neo-nazi
terrorist group the NSU had killed 10
people is the far-right threat stills
that strong in our fear of Islamic
terrorists have we perhaps taken out
eyes off it thanks for the guitar for
its Larissa from Terrell resource job of
a misty yida forum fun goodbye I think
we have to take every form of violence
and terror and their dangers very
seriously whether from the right or the
left things especially when it's based
on religion yes that's a threat to
people's security in Germany we have to
take it seriously I mentioned in
deutschland or decide missing busy and
slimming off also from the right Jana
truly alfani yes of course from the
right it should not be underestimated
also because of our history but not only
by shiny for the speakers and about the
big campaign issue will probably be the
euro crisis after all not that others
will have monster game but your party
has always been regarded as somewhat
skeptical of Brussels do you think that
to save the euro there was no
alternative to the policies that you
yourself supported if ended is our
philly greedy it was completely
justified to demand that the countries
that ran into trouble because of their
budgets the eurozone's problem countries
do their homework they were given time
through credits and guarantees but they
had to use that time to meet the
requirements of the so-called troika
that meant consolidating their budgets
and enacting structural reforms to make
their economies more competitive
inspiration destructor that was the
right path to bring in damn it see a
pitcher in my opinion it was the only
way to reach the going that's each
country within the eurozone must be
competitive on its own so that the
eurozone can be competitive as a unit
the oil realm in schism of international
with perhaps Vegas lyptus being in the
euro crisis we've had heated debates
over not only how Europe should reform
but whether more authority should be
transferred to Brussels what does the
party skeptical of Brussels think ties
in polish listen in in Europe we
certainly have to monitor economic and
financial policy better that's the
lesson of our experience in the last few
years in [ __ ] in yacht and alito but
isn't it also discouraging that the
country's simply haven't been sticking
to the rules that they signed up to if
they had we probably wouldn't have had
the euro crisis at all this is why is in
the top tip it was and is indeed
discouraging and it took place because
Germany at the time governed by an SPD
green coalition in collaboration with
the French government unilaterally
softened the binding criteria that had
been negotiated under former Chancellor
Helmut Kohl and tear Weigel at the
European level oh that was practically
an invitation to other countries to
follow their example that can't be
allowed to happen again this doesn't
mean transferring all possible authority
to Brussels but we should in this area
in economic and financial policy and in
upholding stability policy boutique
definites politics in her tongue and it
stop it incidentally I think it's
outstanding that we've hammered out a
fiscal pact among the states of night
abend us behind in fiscal pact that was
a huge achievement stopping harm her
phora this doesn't mean that all
possible authority has to be transferred
to your own competence in the hotel park
or that european institutions like the
commission presume that they can expand
their own scope and regulate matters
that don't have to be European matters
one example would be drinking water
budget was attempting plaza as over the
Europe of regions was always a pet
project for the CSU there's also the
difficult term subsidiarity which the
CSU has always championed it's the
principle that people should do
everything that they are able to do and
Brussels should only be concerned with
things that affect everyone certainly
that's still your demand regarding the
elections
whenever your party with strong
conservative governments have also been
strong do you think the results will be
good for you via to lalas this is
striking we're doing everything we can
to achieve that was its own at the
moment we're in a good position at the
events we've been holding we see how
much people agree with us and Trust
Chancellor Merkel our regional and party
leaders and the policies of the cdu/csu
it's very apparent cause it's an indie
politic we're seeing very little desire
for change this is shibu bar but we do
have to keep working and fighting for
every vote until the last day yeah but
its own to give water increasingly
voters are delaying their decisions
until the last minute and that's why we
have to fight to the last minute forever
even Lord when dick noch besser lets me
know to engage estimate severe
philosophy Thank You Kenny